hello everyone and welcome to some
extremely exciting news for those of you
who still haven't heard uh here are the
news kasparov
uh yes former world champion gary
casparo will face current world champion
magnus carlson
uh in a chess 960 showdown uh after well
after some 16 years after their their
last
match up so uh here's what's happening
uh here's a nice uh article
uh by peter dodgers for for chess.com as
you can see
carlson caspar will clash for the first
time in 16 years two traditional
tournament or
tournaments organized by saint louis
chess club will be held
online next month so the championships
showdown
it's the chess 9lx i still don't know
why they're still calling it that
doesn't sound all that impressive
it's basically chess 960 or fischer
random uh from
september 11th to september 13th that
ended the saint louis
rapid and bliss from september 15th to
19th uh the first tournament is a round
robin this year meaning that uh gary
caspar and magnus carlson will meet in
an official event for the first time
since 2004
and here are the other participants of
the chess
960 showdown so uh magnus carlson
fabiano corona maxime bashar lagrave
wesley so
and gary casparo so it's going to be uh
i think this is going to be
more more exciting than a lot of stuff
that we've had
like in the in the previous uh few
months or maybe in an entire year
because
here the positions that will happen in
these games will be completely crazy so
no opening theory just uh you know good
old
uh good old tactics and you know just
just going all out
so it's going to be it's going to be a
great tournament i can't can't wait to
see how how gary will do against um
against this field uh you know there are
some older players here but also
some very young ones like alireza
ferruccia and here even though uh
we've uh covered all the games that
kasparov ever played against magnus
carlsen i will also put
links to those those three games in the
description below
i decided to redo one of them it's a
game from their 2004
rapid tournament in reykjavik and it's
really really an impressive game
so uh without further ado let's check it
out and uh before
before we check out this game i would
just like to say that uh
i've created a telegram channel for
those of you who wanna
who are maybe having troubles uh
receiving notifications from youtube so
you can join our telegram channel and i
will also post it there uh whenever i
post a video
and also if i'm having like like a small
private tournament that i'm not uh
gonna publish online or if there are
some really interesting chess news i'm
just gonna
link you out to the news so you can you
know uh stay up to date so if you want
the link will be in the description
below the first thing you will see then
you will see the link to the three games
we've already covered between magnus and
kasparov but for those of you who are
new to chess or maybe new to the channel
this is one of their games from the 2004
matchup
in the rapid reykjavik tournament so
magnus
has the white pieces here uh it's a it's
a knockout
event and the magnus lost where when
kasparov had the white pieces so now
magnus needs to equalize the force
uh to force tie breaks and it's a 25
minutes per player
plus a five second increment per move so
magnus with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have d5
c4 and c6 uh the
uh slav defense is on the board we have
knight f3 and now knight to f6
okay by kasparov knight to the c3 and e6
now
so closing uh closing the structure here
we have bishop to g5
and now knight b to d7 so this was all
uh
very standard stuff at the time and and
still is
we have e3 and now queen to a5 the most
popular move
still up to up to this date in 2020
knight beat to d2 you're
you're fighting for uh the e4 square
because now you you've unpinned
the knight from f6 can now move you're
playing knight to e4
and so magnus in in expectance of that
goes knight to d2
so now this knight is no longer pinned
you can move it and you will be able to
capture here if knight e4 for example is
played
with bishop to b4 kasparov piles up on
the c3 knight
threatening just to capture it and hear
queen to c2 defending
if you try some sort of a weird
developing move you have to be careful
for example if you play something like
bishop to b3 then d
captures on c4 is a very uh very natural
mistake you can make as it comes
with a double attack and you're going to
lose one of your bishops or rather you
have to go into something like this
bishop captures on f6 c captures and e3
and now you either capture allow this or
you go back with the bishop for example
bishop h4 now b6
and uh well now just bishop a6 is coming
in this pawn will be a monster here
and i forgot to mention i will link you
the entire article uh by peter dodgers
in the description below so you can read
a bit more about
the upcoming event so instead after
bishop before we have queen c2 this is
uh all standard stuff and here kasparov
castles with bishop to e2 magnus also
prepares the castle
and now there are some moves you can
play here like c5 you can go for this
you can play d captures on c4
uh but as carlson's king is still in the
center of the board kasparov goes for e5
uh he wants the bust open the center and
also at some point he wants to get his
light square bishop into the game
so uh we have castles by magnus and now
e captures on d4 advancing this pawn all
the way to e4 does seem like it creates
a very strong pawn chain
but it's actually white who's uh who's
enjoying this tension as white has
pressure on the center and at some point
once you
develop all your pieces if you kick away
the bishop with a3 get the rook into the
game you can always undermine the center
with f3 and then just uh you know
enjoy your own uh center so instead
kasparov
plays e captures on v4 and now not
recapturing right away but first a very
important uh
tuition suit knight to b3 with an attack
on the queen so you have to react
to this queen to b6 and only now e
captures on d4
uh we have d captures on c4 uh bishop
captures on c4 and now
a5 because power wants to play a4 kick
away one of the
kick away the defender of the of the
pawn here uh so naturally magnus needs
to prevent this and he prevents it with
a4 and now the queen no longer need it
here we have queen back to c7
putting pressure along this diagonal
bishop the d6 is also coming knight the
g for
knights the g4 might be an idea uh
putting a lot of pressure on carlson's
king side and here
rook ate the e1 by magnus and now you
could
try a lot of things for example the b6
was a tried in this position queen to d6
was also
attempted in this position but the move
caspar plays h6
was a new move uh back in 2004 and it
still is today
and it is as a move 15 that this
position has never been reached again
so magnus needs to decide do we go back
do we capture do we go to h4
a lot of a lot of possibilities here
magnus decides to keep the tension
as he wants to make it problematic for
kasparov to
develop this knight somewhere as he
always wants to have this option
not that of capturing on f6 so here
you could actually do it with knight b6
because the bishop on c4 is undefended
for example but then comes the bishop d4
and you could simply remaneuver the
knight here or you could capture here
but it's uh not not really a problem uh
knight to d5 would be better if you go
for something like uh
uh first uh knight here and now it's not
a problem because the
uh knight knight is guarded that's what
i wanted to say so here
we have bishop back to the sexy back as
part of putting pressure on the h2 pawn
and now while you could defend with
bishop to g3 magnus still
still wants to keep this tension going
happening here so
h3 now uh if you move you can always
just capture
on f6 but this is exactly what kasparov
does knight to b6 as the bishop on c4 is
still
undefended and now we have a trade here
bishop captures on f6
knight captures on c4 and now knights
the e for by magnus
opening up an attack on the on the
knight here and putting pressure on the
bishop on d6
so you could just defend it with bishop
to e6 but kasparov
really wants to keep his bishop pair so
he finds bishop to h2 with
check we have king the h1 by magnus and
then now
uh what do you do here well here
kasparov finds a knight
to d6 and now uh it's a it's a question
what do you do here your
uh your knight is being pressured now uh
but
also there are some other possibilities
for example the the bishop is now
uh undefended so maybe you can capture
that so
there are there are a lot of things you
could play you could play f4 you could
just
make a slow move so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the best
move while i give you a couple of
seconds as it's really
just a wonderful position
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on playing the
most well un un uh welcoming king
captures an h
whoa what's that sorry about that i did
not know you could do that
uh king captures an h2 uh it looks
really weird because you're just going
in front of the queen and you know
allowing yourself some very nasty
discoveries
but the problem is if you go for knight
captures first and bishop captures thing
kasparov got
what he won and he keeps the bishop pair
he the light square bishop is still
under attack and after the bishop moves
you're going to play b6 get the bishop
into the game this way
and black will just have a very very
pleasant game
so magnus finds the absolute strongest
move king captures an h2
so you allow some very nasty discoveries
but the problem is there's only one
nasty discovery and that's knight
captures an e4
check which kasparov plays but now the
problem is bishop to e5 getting your
bishop out of harm's way and also
attacking kasparov's queen
while the knight is also under attack so
you have to go knight to d6 and now you
see
this position is much better than the
one where uh
kasparov had a dark square bishop here
now there's a knight here the knight is
nicely pinned
and again we need to find a nice move
for for for white and here
is where uh it's crucial to to play
to play it correctly and to put the the
most tension
on garrick as power of uh so what would
you play here
once again feel free to pause the video
and try try and figure out what to play
here uh while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations as it's
you know deciphering this position is
what
what it's all about and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
uh it's d5 d5 seems to be the way to go
here because magnus went for a similar
idea
but we're going to discuss that as well
magnus played queen to c5 first he put
pressure on the knight here because the
knight is pinned
but we're first going to show what
happens after d5 d5 is excellent because
it frees up this diagonal for the queen
queen to c3 and the bishop battle will
go after the g7 pawn
and also you cannot capture because the
queen and c7 would be hanging so here
rook d8 adding another defender to the
knight now queen c3
putting pressure on g7 now you defend
with f6 and bishop to g3 still keeping
the tension the knight cannot move the
pawn cannot capture queen d7
you have to move the queen somewhere but
you can't move away from the defense of
the pawn because
you don't want to lose the pawn here but
now comes
knight to c5 and whatever you do you
will lose a pawn for example
queen f7 you're going to play d captures
in c6
b captures and now rook to d1 put a
double attack on the knight here
and now whatever whatever black plays
for example knight b7 you just trade
everything
captures captures you're gonna go
captures captures with
check and now for example queen captures
on a5
uh you will win the a5 pawn and after
black attempts the trade and tries to go
for for an endgame you're going to go
queen b6
attacking the bishop c5 and we we have
this very nice position where black is
threatening checkmate
but after this f3 move we get this
position where white is up upon
and it's a past a pawn and this is uh
the best way for whites to
to play this setup whether magnus would
win this it's hard to say it's a rapid
game
but it is uh it is definitely known that
he would have
er excellent chances here probably
winning chances
so after knight to d6 this is this is
definitely the way to go magnus tried a
very similar idea he played queen to c5
first
uh with the idea of pushing d5 next as
this comes with a threat
but now the thing is kasparov can just
play rook to d8
and now you don't have the c5 square
available for your knight that's one
thing
but magnus still figures out a way how
to how to win a pawn he pushes d5 now
and still the knight is pinned the pawn
cannot capture but now queen d7
and now you have time knights to d4 now
with
a triple attack here and now the problem
is uh this is beautiful what magnus
prepared here because if
kasparov wants to trade off the pawn now
with pawn captures here
the problem is that now magnus easily
wins the game with queen captures on d6
this
is his point captures captures we have
captures and
now rook the e8 check only moved king h7
and now rook to c1
and black loses the bishop here and with
it the game so this was his plan
how he how he decided to win the pawn as
now kasparov
doesn't really have a good move here but
kasparov has one move
knight to f5 and now again uh what do
you play here
well now you do actually win a pawn uh
so d
captures on c6 magnus does win upon b
captures and now
knight captures on c6 attacking the rook
here
and now rook to e8 and here uh magnus
just plays
rook to d1 so he attacks the queen first
queen to e6 and now rook after e1
so this is the position that he got
instead of that one that we've shown
so he is up upon but black has a lot
more options than the one that we've
shown where magnus would already have a
past eight pawn so kasparov goes bishop
b7
uh this is definitely the diagonal that
this bishop needs to
needs to control uh and here magnus goes
back knight to d4
offering some traits here as the queen
and knight are under attack
knight captures and now queen capture
the bishop captures looks nice but after
queen g6 threatening checkmate
doesn't really do anything so it's
better to capture with the queen
putting pressure on the g7 pawn so
kasparov defends it while attacking
queen to g6 again threatening checkmate
here and while you could defend with f3
magnus doesn't really feel like uh
creating more weaknesses uh he instead
just offers a queen trade with queen to
g4
f3 here would probably make the game a
lot more complicated but
uh we can't forget that magnus is still
very young here and he is facing
uh you know the the the beast of baku
gary caspar so he wants to go
queen to g4 and now we have queen
captures on g4 because power of gladly
trades we have h captures and now bishop
to c6 now it's a
uh two rooks are still on the board for
each players but uh we have opposite
colored bishops
and kasparov would very very gladly draw
this with the black pieces so here b3
defending the pawn and now f6 uh
challenging the bishop here
bishop to c3 and now kasparov
successfully trades off one of the
rooks rook captures rook captures and
bishop to d5
now attacking the pawn here rook to b1
defending and now
not just yet with rook to b8 to offer
this trade
uh but first caspar brings his king into
the game king f7
we have king to g3 magnus does the same
and now rook to b8 now he wants to offer
this trade
for example captures and captures and
after all is said and done you would
still win this one as it's on a light
square the dark square bishop is
helpless here
so once the bishop moves it's just three
pawns each
uh a completely drawn end game so magnus
does find b4
like we said once b4 is played you will
create at least uh
one one one best pawn uh so a captures
on b4 and now bishop captures on b4 we
have bishop to c4
hack as part of controls the a6 square
you don't want to allow this pawn to
travel too far
a5 and bishop to a6 and now f3
now kasparov just needs to prevent this
pawn from from moving forward
and magnus needs to figure out a way how
to continue pushing this pawn
so king g6 and now came to f4 kasparov
now goes
h5 he's very happy with uh as many
trades as possible
g captures king captures and now rook
the h1 check very important check
as it allows carlson to activate both
his rook and the bishop and he wants to
shift the bishop over to b6
so king g6 and now bishop to c5 uh we
have rook to b2
going after the pawn here if the if the
rook moves maybe some rook to f1 ideas
will be possible
and now king g3 just defending that pawn
we have
rook to a2 attacking the pawn and
kasparov defense and now
king back to f7 and now uh it's
very unclear how how magnus will force
this bishop to move
so rook c1 by kasparov preparing some
ideas like rook to c7 check
so g5 by magnus and rook to c7 with
check king g6 and now rook to c6 with
some
very nasty threats of something like
rook to d8 or d4 going after
the f6 pawn but also putting pressure on
the bishop on a6
and now it's very hard to decide what to
do so uh
kasparov instead goes bishop to f1 now
he also puts pressure here and
here you don't really have a good move
because if you go for something like
bishop to d4 to offer this trade
you even lose the game because just rook
captures here the king has
only one square so you have to go here
and now nasty discoveries for the win
rook c2 check king moves and you just
pick up the rook and of course win the
game
so here after bishop to f1 carlson
really needs to figure out what to do
here
so he played one of the only moves that
are possible here not to blunder the
game and that is bishop to f2
so the the weight of the g2 pawn is now
blocked
and it was in this position and move 52
that the players agreed to
draw because there is there is nothing
more to be done here
now next what would happen caspar would
win win the a5 pawn and now there's
not much not much to play here uh the
material is completely equal and of
course there's there's nothing to do
here
if you go bishop to d4 uh you can just
pretty much do anything bishop to d for
even go rook to a6 and now
there's nothing to be done here so
after bishop to f2 they agreed to a draw
and what what a game uh the last
game ever played between magnus carlsen
and garrick as part of and now they will
face each other again
after after 16 years they have faced
each other again but not in a one-on-one
match
sometimes during some of the st louis uh
events they play
they play this two on two or five and
five and then sometimes they will meet
but one-on-one over the board well
online over the board uh
for for the first time they will face
each other in 16 years
and i'm expecting i'm expecting a great
game and a great match
so i i i mean it's going to be great
so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it and that you don't mind that
i redid this game
i will be redoing from time to time a
lot of the games i covered in the past
as
i don't know i tend to think videos now
are are a bit better and
of higher quality you know at least they
are at if
60 frames per second but maybe even you
know so we will learn some more
information and you know such things
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it i hope you guys are
excited for the event as much as i am
like i said do join the
the telegram a channel the the link to
it will be the first thing you see in
the description below
then will be the link to the yeah peter
dodgers article on chess.com so you can
learn more about these two events
and then the three games between uh
kasparov and carlson that we've already
covered
a long long time ago all in the
description below
so i do hope you enjoyed it i would like
to thank ali gabriel
uh michael brewer robert krechmar martin
uh juba
and schmidty for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing
uh the coverage of the good stuff
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day